emotional insecurity is the biggest
mental cancer in the world and it is
shockingly easy to fix it is called
putting it out there for some of you
that may be you're finally ready to
actually just do therapy for others you
might go radical and say [__] it I'm
gonna do what garyvee just said on stage
and I'm going to literally post it
everywhere and there will be a lot of
pain with that there'll be collateral
damage but you're ready for others
you'll find a different way but the
reason you're not getting what you want
from it is you're not being truthful
with it you're protecting yourself from
yourself yet you're tricking no one